merci de perdre rapidement pour les
grands les beaux via les médias nous
aujourd'hui on est sur moi de boxe et
finalement comme le propre est en gros
on est tous des boîtes parmi d'autres
boîtes qui ne sont pas des joueurs il
faut trouver quelle boîte sur les
joueurs pour les éliminer c'était la
meilleure explication de toute ma chaîne
youtube vous êtes prêt je vous laisse
cette seconde top-12 trophy cap 5 6 7
alors un petit délinquant
je ne trouve pas bien la fille de
suivants arrête c koi tu que je sais pas
où et mika jah td au québec c'est bien
mais des tu voles à mazamet où l'un si
ce n'est pas resté non justement s'il
serait pas resté en plein milieu pour
qu'on est parti du milieu
tiendront durant dix ans par l'eau mais
c'est pas possible chez nous et il est
simple de mélo mais j'étais dans toutes
les caisses
comment je vois que lui coûte cher
attendons on a trop sous pression la
santé ne peut pas il peut pas y avoir de
comment il était caché dans l'imaginaire
elle était là au gas electric a
clairement tu es games au hockey on
refait cette fois on va à la plateforme
bleu au dessus et le chasser le projet
trouve donc c'est jan 10 j'arrive là
c'est extrêmement rapide avec son bois à
thaon michael c'est quoi on fait un truc
celui qui cherche il se met en première
personne en vue première personne comme
première personne est allé visiter près
tu conduis qu'a dit si tu fermes les
yeux à
je sais la bande à damon et piquant vrai
je te voyais pas mais aussi de
technologies corp allez c'est parti avec
hachette où ils peuvent être ces combats
qu'est ce que c'est que cette pile
énorme à l'état
je suis sur une année de merde internet
par la liberté vous êtes là vous allez
hop ça dégage suivant aulas lucas ou
est-ce qu'il peut être me diallo yacouba
tabac lance pic à sénart des îles où ce
coût alors bon certes apparu c'est le
but et nagent pas où il est il a disparu
et tout le monde va le prendre pour le
mec h à lieu à choix s'avère fort mais
c'est le mec avec moi super fort ça y
est je suis hantée tête était passé
voilà voilà voilà normal plus ni même
plus c'est la merde dans la bastonnade
j'ai paniqué ok on change de chats
maintenant yann c toi 7 8 9 10 et
sérieux non non non on trouve pas avec
moi j'ai sué qui transpirait attendez
c'est pas possible
mais c'est pas possible j'ai fait tout
cela
a comme la vraie merde amertume et je
parie de la vie bon ben ça et 7,8 à tan
tan tan non c'est trop tard on n'attend
pas de toute façon j'ai transpiré
mondiaux et bajaur
je te jure rats et l équateur où j'ai
tué le alors rien jusqu'à ce que le web
c'est là j'ai bien lancé ma main de la
souris pour être sûr de la cacher at
home use nouvelles règles celui qui
meurt quand il revient c'est lui qui
doit chercher les deux autres 8-9-10
lâcheté royal actuellement à tu me vois
la gestion des boîtes de bois qu'est ce
qui se passe ça va ça va alors laissez
auteurs petit café mois appareils
theekoye le prends pas mal hein j'ai pas
de boisson oui mais j'y arrive pas ok
mais un bon casque s'est emmêlé et non
mais je suis calé rachète pas grave
parce que ya des nuls à chier c'est ça
le sous-système rappelle un peu les
habitants à tort car à pattes en tout
cas chez j'espère juste à côté des
pêcheurs étaient cachées des comptes
itunes
moi je fais je vais faire un petit clip
you may quand tu reviendras tu seras
mort mon pote alors terres les plus
sèches mois et étaient les prix les
petites ont reculé qu'est ce que tu fais
allez allez vas-y on t'attend ah je vois
la ballade you et perd le ballon
moi je suis à côté à ben je suis là ah
bah voilà je t'ai vu tu as aussi en
guinée ses doigts tu m'as tu alors
jamais tu as un gars qui étaient cachées
des porte chars à voile de fait jamais
nous avait déjà usé pas eu je crois pas
vous n'êtes pas bien mais qu'un verger
un spot en baskets chou blanc qu'elle
sonne bien mais la laïcité un sport de
glisse turquie serbie exactement noter
là on était tout à l'heure y a pas pire
cachette cas là je suis peut être un
yan tu te tapes une barre alors oui elle
bat ryan sortie c'est mika
moi je suis envahie l'entrée devant moi
michael toi y'a du boulot tu bosses tu
chauffes note un peu plus voilà non non
je te jure je les guide vers mika
prendrait la tête des froids détroit
tire une balle je suis dit tu es 3 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 après 9 et enfin disent ok vous
avait fusionné bande de bâtards j'ai la
vision est pas fait l est pas mais
jamais vous faisons pareil en fait on
essaie d'aller départ fait pas d'abord
une voix comment vois tu je ne peux d'un
modèle super samaha alors baer perdu est
mort je te mangerais père je te venge
mayotte et ben je viens de cette vidéo
sur moi te proches n'étaient pas aimé ça
vous a plu
et c'était les perdreaux lis que c'est
pas l'un de nos jeux préférés les gars
quand même bref et puis c'est surtout
qu'on a trouvé les bonnes règles
ouais puis surtout on a pu fusionner
ensemble et ça
on avait pu faire avant c'est un croyant
ouais c'est vrai c'est vrai de l'amour
fou balle est toujours voulu fusionner
que ouais moi moi j'applaudis pour cette
vidéo à la tête de projeter nous n'était
pas facile voire à la chaîne de yann et
le twitter de mikado tuant tout le monde
à irin
voilà j'attendais ça ftp